Hello internet!
I'm primarily Andrew Heaton,
and you're watching Mostly Weekly.
And I'll bet you clicked that headline because
you wanna see boobs.
Well what if I told you that was click-bait,
pervert,
and we're actually going to talk about the
FCC.
No, I'm just kidding, we're going to talk
about boobs,
and, to a lesser extent, the FCC.
Now I could show you side boob, inner boob,
under boob, or quantum boob,
but I can't show you a composite of all four
because that would be "wrong"
The FCC, for example, considers female nipples
a sexual organ.
What makes the areola a sexual organ?
The gender of the person it belongs to.
Which brings us to America's favorite game
show:
Name that Nipple!
Is this nipple Salma Hayek's
or Paul Giamatti's?
And censorship is a weird to begin with.
For all the thought the FCC puts into nippledom,
they don't bother regulating violence.
So I could show you this:
But I couldn't show you this:
We should be able to show both.
Now if you were offended by that,
note that that human female was my head writer
Sarah
who both wrote and approved that joke.
Isn't that right Sarah?
Thanks Sarah.
Now there's one group of people that aren't
afraid of boobs
and that's babies.
But if they're allergic to formula, they're
in trouble.
Because it's hard to buy breast milk.
And breast milk is incredibly healthy for
infants.
And even body-builders are trying to use it
for growing muscles.
Because who's more jacked than a baby?
But between one and five percent of women
in the US
don't produce enough breast milk to feed their
kids.
In fact, when I Googled 'breast milk'
one of the top suggested searches to pop up
is 'for sale.'
Now despite the huge demand, it's incredibly
difficult to buy breast milk.
Even though there's more than enough supply.
There are only two dozen donation based milk
banks in all of North America,
and they don't have enough milk.
And even when they do it'll set you back up
to four dollars an ounce
which is about six hundred dollars a week
for most mothers.
Breast milk doesn't have to be the cognac
of body fluids.
We can compensate women for their milk,
that'll increase the supply while making it
cheaper for needy mothers.
And that's exactly what the internet did.
This amazing site offers breast milk for as
low as fifty cents an ounce.
They even have different categories,
there's organic, gluten free, and vegan.
If you want your baby to grow up to be a commie.
But for now businesses like this are operating
in a gray market.
Which means it's the about this legal:
The FDA sees breast milk marketplaces as a
liability
and local lawmakers see it as exploitative.
So let's turn the gray market,
into a great market!
[groans]
So I see only two solutions
One: breast milk exchange companies
coat the exterior of their building with female
nipples.
That way they'll be obscured from view and
can operate privately and securely.
Or we can update the way we see breasts as
just another beautiful part of the human anatomy
and women can do whatever they want with their
own bodies.
And look, I'm all for being ashamed of our
bodies
because I'm a WASP.
But I think we should be ashamed of every
part of our body,
not just the breasts.
Well thanks for watching Mostly Weekly,
I'm somewhat Andrew Heaton...
or am I?